bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs diagonale c'est la rentrée
puisque ça fait un mois et demi que nous
vous avions quitté pour l'été et
aujourd'hui nous recevons donc
évidemment le grand stéphane laborde
bonjour bonjour bonjour stéphane et moi
je vois loi donc un été chaud chaud
chaud dans un championnat de france où
contre toute atteinte finalement tu a
brillé oui tout à fait première chose
déjà le champion de france sera le thème
central de cette émission puisque nous
avons recueilli la bad et des reportages
des interviews
donc ça le coeur de cette émission sera
le championnat de france
maintenant effectivement bon ce qu'il
faut voir en premier c'est pas le fait
que le présentateur un des présentateurs
de diagonale et bien joué mais plutôt
que etienne bacrot et remporté la
compétition pour la troisième fois
consécutive en phase active mais c'était
la plus difficile peut être des trois
fois puisque il a fallu recourir au
départage avec deux autres joueurs ont
mais à chaque fois il avait un an de
moins des fois précédentes
donc il était jeune on rappelle qu
etienne bacrot n'a que 18 ans donc il a
gagné à 16 ans la compétition ce qui est
de vraiment très jeune records de
précocité
ensuite trois fois consécutives stéphane
encore c'est un record ça n'a jamais eu
lieu en france tout simplement rappelé
que fisher je crois que gagner cinq fois
de suite le championnat des états unis
ont commencé à 14 ans on commence à 14
ans il faudrait que etienne où on gagne
à peu près cinq fois ça me fait encore
deux toiles c'est déjà trop tard
déjà trop tard pour faire mieux au
niveau de l'âge à noter que donc cette
édition marseillaise était d'excellente
qualité
plus de 1200 joueurs c'est leur corps
qui est tombé une fois de plus l'ancien
record était détenu par le champion de
france de besançon donc énorme quantité
de joueurs très haut niveau de jeu
puisque le national de cette édition
2001 marseillaise était le plus relevé
qu'il n'ait jamais eu de 1562 moyenne et
aux traits forts
ça prouve donc bien que les échecs
français progresse mais ça progresse à
noter aussi que le féminin progresse
le national féminin mais quand même un
bon niveau aussi bon c'est évidemment
c'est vrai
niveau ces rapports de sexe féminin
c'est 2002 à peu près la moyenne de 1200
peut-être même moins d'être moins mais
marie sebag n'a pas réussi à conserver
son titre
le national féminin effectivement il
faut en parler puisque les faire jouer
aux échecs ça quand même le rappeler
donc effectivement victoires de maria
leconte qui bat marie séveno départage
alors stéphane analyses de l'expert est
ce que l'expérience l'a emporté sur la
jeunesse et la fougue de mari ce bug
ouais je pense que effectivement marie
lecomte a très bien joué
enfin moi je suivais les parties du
féminin même temps que ce que je suis
allé voir quelques jours le championnat
voilà rappelons enfin expliquant quand
même que tu es venu à marseille pour
jouer le championnat du monde d'échecs
marseillais ouais et avant de partir en
vacances à corfou chez les grecs
et donc je sais pas je pense que marie a
raté probablement sa partie contre
lecompte sa partie officielle en fin de
partie longue elle aurait pu l'europe et
l'emporter j'avais quand même initiative
enfin façon anecdotique et puisque chez
les hommes il faut noter le super
parcours de détiennent bacrot et aussi
les beaux parcours de christian bauer et
jean-marc de kraft alors on va y venir
on va juste rappeler quand même que
marianne leconte et maryse bagues ont
gagné la compétition avec trois points
d'avancé
c'est donc en fait tout simplement une
boucherie les autres jeunes filles ou
jeunes femmes n'ayant tout simplement
pas existé pas été à la hauteur de ces
deux joueuses exceptionnelles notamment
marie se bat qui quand même n'a que 14
ans il faut le rappeler donc victoires
de maria le compte devant harry sebag
maintenant nous allons passer peut-être
ses fans avant de passer au national
masculin puisque on a beaucoup
d'interviews à diffuser nous allons
parler un peu de l'accession avec la
présence de marc santoro mans qui est
donc notre premier sujet marc santoro
mans le joueur toulousain toujours très
sympathique qui avait justement à
l'occasion de cette interview un peu mal
aux yeux puisque je crois qu'il s'était
mal réveillé donc tout de suite en
images marquent santoro un jour nous
sommes ici au championnat de france
d'échecs de marseille avec marc santoro
mans le joueur le plus expérimenté du
circuit de trois fois champion de france
et ici nous avons etienne bacrot qui
gagne pour la troisième fois consécutive
marc c'est l'exploit ah ben ouais ça il
également record mais il a fait dresser
cultive m'ennuie c'est bien l'autre hic
c'est mieux ah oui c'est vrai c'est
toujours mieux et surtout qu'il a joué
au moins une fois comment
alors marc quand est ce qu'on te reverra
dans le national est bien là j'ai échoué
dans ses choix de jeu aujourd'hui fini
juste troisième au pied du quai de la
qualif et j'espère me qualifier avec le
avec léonie prochaine
toi qui a connu énormément de
championnat de france que peux tu dire
de cette édition marseillaise c'était
c'était mieux que l'année dernière pour
les résultats et puis sinon
l'organisation c'était pas mal mais
c'était hors cei
il fait c'est mieux dans le sud quand
les milices essaiment pas maxauto moment
merci merci loin voilà marc santoro mans
toujours très sympathique à noter qu'il
a échoué d'un cheveu comme il le mérite
il ya plus beaucoup
donc s'il en perd à chaque fois c'est un
terrain à chaque fois il va dans dix ans
la touche à tout à fait le marque son
retour au mans donc toujours très
sympathique toulousain vous pouvez le
voir évidemment il est venu dans des
gones halle et nous a parlé de
l'accession dans la lah l'émission
précédente marsan tourments qui termine
à la place qu'on qualifie du premier
baiser
stéphane puisque il ya 2 quelle place
pour les qualifiés mars entre romands et
3e - dans les trois accessions
dangereuses les deux qualifiés sont 6
rue marcellin et emmanuelle marie carrié
manuel bricard emmanuel bricard qui est
un habitué du national puisqu'il a déjà
été champion de france en 1994 ou 15 et
donc les jours plusieurs fois nationale
emmanuel bret carr qui est un très très
bon joueur habitué
alors que si raymond marcellin lui c'est
un jeune joueur on l'a reçu dans des
gones al d'ailleurs oui il ya quelques
quelques temps maintenant costard
condamné parce que ça fait quand même
bientôt trois ans que les gones elle
existe revenez du championnat du monde
junior tout à fait et donc cyril
marcellin joueur très solide
ces partis sont ennuyeuses mais
attention elles sont quand même très
technique il faut dire qu'il a un style
technique
pas flamboyant mais efficace donc à la
petroci un angle peut-être pas tant même
que cette pas quand même en tout cas
donc victoire d'emmanuel bricard dans
cette accession rappelle l'accession il
y avait à peu près 150 joueurs c'est le
temps de réserver aux joueurs
internationaux
victoire donc des manuels bricard
deuxième sur une marcellin qui gagne la
dernière ronde contre un endroit frais
et marque son tourment n'arrive pas
glisser dans la partie termine troisième
ensuite on retrouve tout un tas une
jeune coureur on peut encore se
qualifier au classement elo c'est ce
qu'ils disaient ça paraît peu probable
malheureusement puisque
les échecs français comme on l'a dit
progresse très vite on arrive donc à la
compétition phare stéphane avec tout
d'abord dans ce tournoi place aux jeunes
robert fontaine dont il réalise
l'exploit way qui se qualifie en poule
haute puisqu'il partait 16e comme voilà
c'est ça il partait dernier il réussira
bien être très solide dans la première
phase et gagne la dernière partie à
l'arraché avec les noirs contre arnaud
contre arnaud hauchard qui devait aussi
l'emporter c'est hier que les deux
joueurs devaient l'emporter pour se
qualifier et est rare nous a pris un peu
trop de risques et finalement c'est
robert qui empochent le point et qui se
qualifie pour la poule où tout n'a pas
été ridicule mais non et surtout
stéphanie l'a fait normes de grands
maîtres sa deuxième nombre de grands
maîtres il a 20 ans on va le voir dans
l'interview il dit lui même que ce n'est
pas exceptionnel mais enfin il y en a
pas beaucoup qui menace de devenir
grands maîtres à 20 ans c'est quand même
assez jeune donc tout de suite
robert fontaine l'exploit de ce national
nos grands maîtres avec robert fontaine
qui réalise un exploit puisqu'il était
remplaçant et qu'il termine dans la
poule haute donc très belle prestation
petit détail et un peu ton parcours
robert ouais ouais donc la première
phase de la poule j'ai réussi à la gigue
mal commencé j'ai fait un demi sur deux
j'ai perdu contre
walser et après j'ai réussi à me
remettre et j'ai terminé à +1 finalement
en battant arnaud hauchard matin au char
à la dernière donc ça m'a permis de me
qualifier quoi tu réalises ici ta
deuxième normes de grand maître tu es
très jeune donc tu vas bientôt des
grands maîtres et tu es prometteur web à
20 ans de normes ça rien d'exceptionnel
non plus quoi mais bon c'est pas mal ça
va professionnels pas encore non
pourquoi pas non il ya la fac et choses
crée à la fac donc j'ai essayé d'y aller
je suis un peu faible encore pour être
pro donc voilà je vais essayer de gérer
les deux quand même un tournoi très
satisfaisant ici ouais je très content à
mon seul regret c'est d'avoir un père du
contraire leur rôle anges puisque ça m'a
empêché de terminer dans les cinq
premières places quoi effectivement
c'est dommage robert merci c'était une
partie des bills voilà robert fontaine
donc qu'il regrette d'avoir perdu et
bien contre moi mais effectivement les
petits jeunes et bien s'il faut encore
qu'il travaille un petit peu en tout cas
j'ai battu robert fontaine sur une
partie tout à fait sympathique en tout
cas vu de mon côté ce qui m'a donc
permis justement de prendre sa place et
que puisque j'avais un 10 points de
retard je suis passé 1 et pointe en
avance en le battant robert fontaine
donc robert fontaine a noté stéphane
qu'il était remplaçant oui c'est à dire
qu'il n'était pas dans la première liste
des qualifiés mais toi aussi et moi donc
le site n'était pas dans la première
liste des qualifiés pour le championnat
est en fait suite au désistement de deux
marchés à nos jeux croix et de ses
martyrs alès le couple marciano amiral
nr fonder une société qui s'appellerait
peut-être martyrs alès mais on n'en sait
pas plus sur la société
en tout cas deux joueurs se sont
désistés dont qualification à larache de
robert fontaine et moi même qui avons pu
participer à la compétition dès c'est
vrai qu'en plaçant ça donne un petit
plus c'est quand même assez motivant
bien tarco annick chaussis qui s'est
désisté du nom puisqu'il était troisième
remplaçant est étrangement pas tout à
fait donc voilà donc robert fontaine
nombre de grands maîtres c'est bien
on le rappellera jamais assez maintenant
nous allons passer à une interview très
intéressante stéphane le joueur le plus
polémique du circuit toujours un avis
tranchant intéressant ce n'est pas joël
lautier qui aurait pu faire office de
professeurs c'est le professeur russe
france et maintenant iossif dorfman tout
de suite en images toujours top top et
nous sommes ici avec iossif dorfman
bonjour votre jeu cette édition était
particulièrement relevé avec une moyenne
de 2560 est ce qu'on peut dire que les
échecs français ont progressé sans aucun
doute c'est incomparable avec les
chemins des années impressionnante
c'est un moment qu'il rassemble déjà
leur championnat de l'union soviétique
on rappelle que tu as été champion
d'union soviétique en 1976 si je ne dis
pas d'erreur 77 effectivement donc tu
peux comparer ta prestation ici n'était
pas vraiment excellente
qu'est ce qui t'es arrivé dans ce
tournoi je donnais un cadeau tianma
surpris par
le premier de ses quatre jeux puis
annulé pratiquement par n'importe quel
coup mais je ne sais pas il est
franchement elle est arrivée en retard
il n'est pas s'excuser et ça m'a
déstabilisé un pied puis j'ai déconné
assez horrible qu'est ce que j'ai fait
dans cette partie et après les deux
le parcours était très limitée il
fallait faire une course en deux parties
pour assurer la qualification
je les fais avec les difficultés bien
sûr et dans la phase finale j'ai raté
les grands comptes
sokolov j'étais gagner on a complètement
dans cette note qui me laissait encore
une chance pour rattraper et j'avais une
très bonne chance contre degroof
donc j'ai raté deux fois et c'est normal
que j'ai perdu les chances pour être sur
le podium
que penses tu de la formule avec des
poules de qualification c'est une autre
missive
absolument parce que onze jours de
tournois différents et finalement on
commence avec un tournant dans cette
ronde où on pense comment ce que les
filles et dans les dernières rondes
du groupe il y a le jurent qu'ils qui
prend la dernière chance qui donne les
cadeaux aux gens que ce que les filles
pour les pilotes comme comme il l'a fait
dans ce tournoi courau frictionner après
hong kong c'est pour pour le titre qui
est absolument idiot donc on mélange
deux systèmes et le tournoi est très
homogène maintenant je sers mon avis un
moment propice pour revenir à une
formule de toute ronde
d'ailleurs tout les joueurs ont signé
par était comment maintenant les
pétitions au président d échec est donc
une lettre qui circule un petit mot pour
finir sur la prestation des tenga
croquis est quand même remarquable
je n'ai pas vu au malheureux small et
moi j'étais partage été invités
aujourd'hui je vais jetter marché avec
mes amis à un mage tough que c'est des
graves qui avait mérité de devenir
champion de france il était le plus
créatives le plus déterminé etienne
franchement l'était absolument épuisé si
vous regardez les dernières d'où partent
il était tout noir
aucune idée aucune énergie ni rien mais
peut-être très bien j'ai l'image de
départage moi je n'ai pas vu que je
répète un petit mot sur joël lautier
contre-performance quand même c'est
aussi ils étaient les victimes de ce
système parce que je sais comment que si
le terrain plus longue sur 13 15
rondelles plus encore s'est réveillée
mais il était très pressé n'ai pas
réussi à gagner une seule partie donc
évidemment il joue très très bien la
dernière temps je le sais malchance
c'est plutôt le système je crois le site
de fans merci voilà yassif dorfman un
avis toujours tranché alors qu'ils
étaient surpris par étienne macro par le
premier coup et oui oui ça c'est alors
ça vraiment on peut se poser la question
quand on est amateur d'échecs
on voit des grands maîtres
professionnels qui jouent depuis 30 ans
40 ans peut-être même plus
comment peut-il être surpris par le
premier coup on va me dit souvent ça
s'ils dorment ya aussi vas y c'est rossi
qui soviétique qui avait été soi-disant
aussi surpris par par la réaction de
dorfman à son ouverture un peu spécial
il avait joué b3 fougue et deux matchs
alors je pense qu'on va y revenir à
cette perte prend du relief c'est
vraiment un moment fort de ce
championnat grec et puis donc je pense
que bon et c'est une préparation à la
préparation psychologique je pense qu'il
veut dire ça c'est ça il ne s'attendait
pas au premier coup c4 alors que bon et
tiens on sait qu'ils jouent pas ou
quatre ils jouent des quatre oui bon qui
joue ses quatre premiers coups c'est pas
bon ça ça change pas beaucoup de choses
par rapport à des cas pourquoi
disons que ça change ça change parce que
en fait une cible de romanet
probablement préparé une arme qui ne
marche que sur des 4 et pas sur ces 4
donc une fois qu'il peut plus la jouer
effectivement il a été surpris donc en
fait ça se joue à l'ordre de coup
certaines rentes ai vite et à éviter
donc ceci fait été surpris par ces
quatre premiers coups bon enfin ceci
n'expliquant pas cela quand même
n'aurait plus se reprendre et faire nul
bien entendu probablement donc aussi
dorfman qui donne un avis aussi sur la
formule stéphane alors ça la formule
orgue et en tant qu'organisateur de
spectacle ouais que peux tu dire sur
cette formule du national on va là
rappeler sept joueurs deux poules de
huit
les quatre premiers de chaque poule à
l'issue des sept premières rondes se
rencontrent en tir croisé et ensuite
celui qui a marqué le plus de points
parmi ces deux fois quatre premiers
remportent l'épreuve
oui c'est vrai ça pose des problèmes
puisque les au final nombre de points
joués dont les grecs les premiers rangs
jouer entre eux c'est sûr mais ils
n'auront pas joué le même les mêmes
joueurs dans la poule basse donc bon
mais comme son nombre de points et
garder sassine poule et un peu
désavantagé par rapport à l'autre c'est
un joueur qui est en méforme par exemple
eh bien ça va ça va ça va créer des
distorsions ça va ça va pas être tout à
fait équitable moi je préférais la
formica vtc ya deux ans avec des
éliminations directes
c'est la formule que je préfère élever
des poules au départ et ensuite
illuminations en direct c'est ce qu'on
fait pour le football il n'y a pas de
raison qu'on ne puisse pas faire ça pour
les échecs ça se fait pour le
championnat du monde fim est aussi ça
sera aussi des inconvénients parce que
c'est difficile de départager du joueur
sur deux parties mais au moins c'est
équitable est bon même s'il peut y avoir
des surprises les qualifs man a été
champion du monde mais on a vu que
l'année d'après c'est un homme qui avec
elle qui a gagné donc agir prendre les
finales et she wolf en demi-finale bon
en football c'est pas toujours la
meilleure équipe qui gagne la coupe du
monde de football donc mais ça donne
toujours un beau champion moi je préfère
la formule élimination directe ça c'est
une formule un peu à mi chemin entre
jonglerie des formules hybrides entre
qualifie ces on n'a pas c'est un choix
non tranché on va dire voilà mon avis
c'est bon on sait que jean paul ii veut
dire les choses à dire pour venir
défendre sa formule il est bienvenu
évidemment sur ce plateau
on en saura plus quand il sera là tout
simplement en tout cas pour l'instant
les joueurs ont tendance à dire qu'il
faut revenir au système toute ronde
compte tenu que les poules sont de plus
en plus homogène il n'y a pas deux il
n'y a pas de faibles joueurs maintenant
ils oscillent dorfman a dit quelque
chose de très intéressant il a dit que
celui qui méritait de gagner le tournoi
c'était jean-marc degraeve qui a été le
plus créatif le joueur le plus créatif a
fait belle partie il a fait des très
belles parties d'attac jean-marc
degraeve c'est sûr donc tout de suite eh
bien nous allons voir ce qu'il a à dire
jean-marc degraeve le 3e marseille nous
sommes ici avec jean-marc degraeve
bonjour bonjour
excellent tournoi donc puisque tu es
premier ex-aequo de ce championnat de
france et une de ses meilleures
performances en championnat tout
simplement
oui c'est une de mes meilleures
performances j'ai raté le titre mais bon
j'ai choisi je n'ai pas trop rater
aujourd'hui j'ai surtout raté contrition
quand j'ai perdu l'avant dernière ronde
oui puisque tu étais à ce moment là seul
en tête du tournoi et +4 et tu est
redescendu à +3 donc c'est ça tu as
peut-être donné un coup au moral
oui ça m'a donné un petit coup au moral
surtout que si je faisais nullement
après je pouvais faire nul avec la
dernière avec les blancs monts c'était
quand même assez possible de suivre nos
fans a déclaré que tu étais le joueur le
plus créatif du tendre qu'est ce qui
nous vaut cette créativité nouvelle
entre guillemets ou alors tu l'a
toujours eue je ne sais pas je crois que
j'ai toujours eu mon maintenant j'ai un
peu plus confiance en moi donc je joue
plus créatif mais bon ça va c'est c'est
peut-être la petite famille
la petite famille nous y venons puisque
donc tu as récemment une petite fille
d'un petit garçon autant pour voir donc
comment ça se passe est ce que c'est on
dit normalement que ça fait perdre des
points lourds et tout ça ouais je sais
pas pourquoi mais mon nom moines
seulement fait gagner bon je sais pas
j'ai un peu plus professionnel on veut
dire un petit mot sur la performance
détiennent qui quand même réalise trois
victoires consécutives qui a remporté
ses matchs au départage assez facilement
finalement oui bon il l'a gagné assez
facilement c'est vrai mais il était
attendu comme je les ai sentis très très
tendue bon je veux dire bon il a joué
solide dans le tournoi et sans plus mais
très solide quoi il a gagné sans forcer
ou sens donc c'est pas une victoire
brillante
ben disons que il a gagné parce que j'ai
perdu aussi quand christian réveille-toi
c'est bon on s'est battus entre nous il
a gagné grâce à ça sinon je crois que
deux rondes avant la fin il n'est pas
temps favori que ça jean-marc degraeve
champion de france c'est pourquoi c'est
pour l'année prochaine merci jean marc
l'année prochaine peut-être si dieu le
veut comme on dit donc en tout cas jean
marc degraeve
qui a joué les matchs se départagent il
est premier ex-aequo avec un atelier
vasseur et etienne bacrot etienne bacrot
s'est imposé en semi rapides allant
quelque chose qui revient constamment
dans le discours des joueurs stéphane
c'est que etienne bacrot n'a pas bien
joué ce tournoi
et pourtant il a gagné qu'est ce que ça
veut dire wayne on peut pas dire qu'il a
mal joué il a quand même pas fait de il
a fait mieux que par exemple que joël
lautier déjà clairement bon il n'a
peut-être pas il n'a peut-être pas fait
des partis beaucoup de parties très très
agressive mais quand même il a fait de
jolies parties notamment sa partie
contre freyssinet était pas mal quand
gina il a réussi à faire ce sacrifice de
nos sacrifices de pions bon on ne peut
pas dire que non peut-être les joueurs
aussi il faut on peut noter bon c'était
le favori avec joël lautier
tous les joueurs ont réussi à faire nul
contre joué à l'hôtel parce que c'était
l'homme à battre
etienne bacrot faisait aussi
probablement partie des hommes à abattre
les joueurs ont probablement joué plus
solide contre lui que contre les autres
il a quand même réussi à surpasser ça
donc c'est dans le contexte est pas
évident qu'il est qui qui mérite pas sa
victoire mais une victoire est toujours
mérité a priori rien en tout cas cela
dit au niveau de la qualité des parties
les joueurs avaient l'air d'accord pour
dire que c'était pas un etienne du ctp
du grand etienne tout simplement
ouais mon bon vent c'est à dire pas de
grand poucet au match des partages
c'était pas du grand jeu elle non plus
quand on est favoris sont passés pas
évident c'est pas évident
ben on aime kasparov
ils arrivent ils arrivent à faire des
tournois où il gagne sans forcément être
très très brillant oui parce que tous
les joueurs veulent pas perdre contre
lui donc il joue les vamps les plus
solides c'est pas évident pour lui de
passer à noter qu etienne était
peut-être non plus pas trop conforme
enfin le mieux pour le savoir c'est
quand même de lui demander directement
donc nous avons une interview du
champion de france 2001 pour la
troisième année consécutive on ne
présente plus etienne bacrot tout de
suite que le champion de france 2001
etienne bacrot qui remporte la
compétition pour la troisième fois
consécutive alors félicitations et merci
comment ça s'est passé c'était facile
plus dur ou moins dur que les éditions
précédentes
à chaque année c'est difficile et c'est
vrai que cette année c'était un peu de
chance parce que par exemple silver
gagne la dernière c'est lui qui est
champion donc ça ne se jouait pas
seulement sur sur mes parties j'ai bien
commencé avec quatre et demi sur cette
même 5 sur 7
on peut le préliminaire mais après après
une grosse gaffe contre robert fontaine
j'étais un peu démoralisés j'ai fait que
quatre nuls
dans la poule haute et heureusement
cette année +3 c'est à dire c'est à dire
7 sur 11
ça c'est pas beaucoup mais seulement 7
sur 11 c'est vraiment pas beaucoup
comparé aux années précédentes et donc
tu remportes le titre quand même oui
mais cette fois c'était c'est beaucoup
plus serré il ya eu plus de nul et le
tournoi était était plus fort aussi donc
il y avait moins de partie facile et
c'était plus serré tu es maintenant un
ambassadeur d échelle entre guillemets
puisque donc tu es représentants de la
france champion de france quel effet ça
te fait d'être si jeunes et déjà de voir
des responsabilités si importante
bah c'est pas pour me déplaire en plus
c'est la troisième fois
j'ai toujours au delà de la réussite au
championnat de france mais je veux
quatre fois la première année j'ai déjà
fait un bon résultat en terminant
deuxième et là j'ai gagné 3,3
précédentes jean duhau des partages et
c'est s'aggrave fait tu vas revenir
ouais je suis très content en plus c'est
ma première ma première victoire de
l'année
j'ai eu des résultats constants est bon
tout au long de l'année mais j'ai pas
gagné 2 j'avais pas de gagner le tournoi
encore ça me fait vraiment plaisir
on peut dire que cette remis en route
pour las
pour le monde le monde entier puisque
quand même champion du monde c'est mieux
que champion de france ouais mais bon
c'est déjà quelque chose je pense que
avec tous les bons joueurs qui étaient
là c'est un bon résultat est bon c'est
parce que le tournoi est est quand même
bien fort que je jouerai les années
prochaines
un petit mot sur joël lautier laurent
frayssinet ouais bah je l étais
peut-être pas très en forme et comme moi
il a eu quatre fois les noirs c'est déjà
un petit désavantage pour passer dans la
poule haute
mais bon c'est vrai que sept nuls c'est
quand même beaucoup
etienne bacrot merci beaucoup et bravo
encore merci qui est très content
d'avoir gagné et on le comprend donc
stéphane un commentaire sur etienne
bacrot non mais il a il confirme un
petit peu cette année-là il a progressé
au classement et où il ya maintenant
tout près de jouer de lautier au
classement lille 25 points mais
je le paie peut-être un classement très
élevé en sert aussi à 2653 je le tiens
de 1175 donc il doit être dans les 50 60
premiers bruits 50 premiers mondiaux
donc il était dans l'histoire l'année
dernière donc il reste donc six continue
est-ce qu'il a pris un nouvel entraîneur
c'est ma part j'y lis toujours non alors
il ya nikitine également août il était
l'entraîneur de garry kasparov est donc
bon mais s'il continue à bien s'entourer
bombe et pourquoi pas arriver dans les
dix premiers mondiaux
et après on sait que tout est possible
surtout si la fidh et garde son système
de jeu balle entendu des deux
championnats du monde par élimination
directe
etienne a les nerfs très solides mais il
faut quand même le dire mais c'est vrai
en match match à des partages donc où ça
se joue en semi rapide il était
extrêmement se relever très fort en semi
rapides aussi fait partie des très très
en vue dans ce but rapide donc il peut
il peut faire la surprise et
et peut-être pas cette année parce qu'il
n'est pas qualifié au champagne on y va
peut-être affabilité quand même c'est
possible qu'ils sont il a été repêché
déjà au mouvement m empêcher donc il va
il va jouer
c'est possible qu'il aille très loin
c'est possible il faut il faut pas
qu'ils craquent il faut que ceux qui
sont en bonnes conditions ça va se jouer
à moscou je crois oui bon il faut kg
demi dieu il faut qu'ils préparent bien
son voyage aussi qu'ils soient bien là
bas et on il peut faire quelque chose et
pourquoi pas si l'arrivée en demi finale
ou quelque chose comme ça mais je pense
que les médias tous les médias français
vont s'emparer se remet sur moscou ça
fait donc c'est possible alors voilà
donc bilan marseillais etienne bacrot
champion de france sur marc degraeve a
extrêmement bien joué cet ordre assez
clair également robert fontaine qui
réalise le nombre de grands maîtres est
tout simplement ce échec total pour
laurent frayssinet et joël lautier qui
ont qui sont tout simplement passés à
côté de leur tournoi il faut le dire
stéphane on va passer maintenant au
coeur de la mission
ouais la fameuse âme au top game comme
intel game la partie commentaires donc
on va se mettre en échiquier en
vignettes et c'est parti pour la partie
de la semaine
ça va venir alors on va voir la partie
freyssinet roland je ferais signer range
alors pourquoi cette partie là non pas
que je sois spécialement content d'avoir
battu laurent frayssinet mais enfin je
le suis quand même un petit peu mais
parce que justement laurent frayssinet
l'avait demandé il a dit à la prochaine
émission diagonale et bien nous
commencerons la partie freyssinet roland
ch quel que soit le résultat alors
évidemment laurent frayssinet devait
venir aujourd'hui il s'est annoncée il a
prévenu qu'il allait arriver
et quand je le dis qu on commentait la
partie live en juin il a eu peur il a
pris peur c'est donc là il a déclaré
piteusement ne pas s'être réveillé
l'émission étant trop tôt 15h30
l'émission bon c'est son choix
donc laurent frayssinet n'est pas là
mais nous allons quand même commenté
c'était fin de cette partie serait
signer roland ries alors à noter que
laurent quand même jouer cette partie on
voulait on a gagné
bien entendu il n'a pas ils ne voulaient
absolument de gagner la partie donc
c'est une partie qui va qui va être
tendu oui exactement donc laurent
frayssinet à ce moment-là ce stade de la
compétition 1 fois et demie sur deux
mois j'ai un point sur deux j'ai fait
deux nuls
non je ne sais plus enfin non il a un
demi point de plus que moi il ya un an
et demi sur trois et moi j'ai un sur
trois donc effectivement il envie de
gagner pour assurer sa qualification en
plus s'ils gagnent 1 il assure la
qualification et de il joue pour le
titre de champion de france en tout 53
iba bâlois est étroit il me bat alors
que je suis son pire cauchemar puisqu'il
n'a pour l'instant jamais battu aussi
surprenant que ça puisse paraître
puisqu'au classement elo il est
évidemment largement favori je suis donc
la bête noire de laurent frayssinet
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas le 4 septembre
se nourrir les blancs c'est son
ouverture un igloo et 4 tout en 1 4 c 5
a pas de surprise kbc 3 donc la petite
russe de laurent frayssinet qui veut
éviter la nage dorff puisqu'on sait que
sur le coup des six maintenant qu'il
veut convertir dans un spécial nador il
peut y avoir la fameuse attaque avec f 4
way la tâte grand prix qui est assez
dangereuse donc ici petite subtilité sur
quelle étrange d'un coup à six pas tout
à fait pareil mais ça retransmise dans
un âge d'or après cavaliers f3
maintenant on joue des six c'est plus
facile des quatre pions prend des quatre
cabinets pendants les quatre points à
ses deux nagent dans ce cas 26 ici
laurent frayssinet joue comme à son
habitude le coup six fours 3 alors il ya
un petit historique entre les deux
joueurs puisque nous avons fait beaucoup
de parties d'entraînement avec laurent
sur cette position
effectivement il m'a beaucoup aidé à
bien cerner les problèmes des noirs et
malheureusement ça s'est retourné contre
lui mais en tout cas cette question
était bien connue de nous deux puisque
chaque fois qu'on joue ensemble et bien
nous avons cette position-là sur
l'échiquier donc une partie hyper
thématiques aussi sa 6e sainte est
possible ie5 est possible et kg 4 est
possible aussi ce donc c'est ce qu'on
recommande dans des gonades la leçon
vous pouvez aller voir le chapitre nash
d'offres sur des gones à la leçon et
bien vous verrez qu'on recommande de 6 g
4 ça c'est une sorte d' attaque
querrey alors ça c'est une attaque très
d'entre elles dangereuses et qu'ils
s'exposent je crois du côté aux côtés
blanc au coût de 5 notamment alors le
coup eux cinq dans cette pétition est
possible sur quoi il ya cavaliers f5 et
après j'ai 6 voilà un sacrifice de
pièces voilà sacrifice de pièces et
notamment il ya une partie super entre
judit polgar à shirov je crois qu'il va
beaucoup mieux il ya eu beaucoup de
parties de très fort joueur on est
arrivé à peu près à la conclusion que
les blancs serez mieux mais c'est pas
sûr puisque à chaque fois qu'il ya un
joueur l'a joué bien il ya il renouvelle
la théorie tout simplement échanges
d'évaluation de la position donc c'est
très compliqué récemment kasparov
il faut suivre le modèle kasparov quand
même qui est la référence en matière de
systèmes dast of il a joué le coup h 6
c'est donc mon choix tout simplement
donc 1,6 pour empêcher 5 h et 5 tout à
fait avez-vous cas pour le retarder
ils ont retardé parce qu'on peut jouer h
quatre tours j'ai un g5 mais ça veut
dire est intense a perdu tant fins à
dire que en jouant simplement le petit
qu'on cache six ont fait perdre du temps
les blancs doivent jouer non seulement
h4 ouais mais aussi déplacé la tour
puisque sinon elle est dans l'alignement
ouais donc on peut plus jouer g5 et
reprendre avec le pion au g5 à noter que
c'est sûr qu'on a envie de faire
les blancs ont envie clairement
d'installer un pion sur cette case pour
chasser le cavani notamment joué g6 qui
casserait la structure des peluches et 6
avec attaque du pion aux séismes est
extrêmement violent là laurent
frayssinet qui connaît très bien cette
position jourdain 2 2
c'est le coût standard le coût tout à
fait standard on veut jouer tout
simplement
grau roig h4 ouais et ensuite un coup
comme fou g2 du poids que 3 ou faux h3
dans l'ordre ou dans le désordre suivi
de g5 un g6
c'est un coup de dé veloppement tout à
fait normal à noter que la dalle est
mieux placée en eux deux camps des deux
il faut choisir la casse puisqu'il n'ya
pas de calais c4 qui attaquera la dame
un accord donc ça c'est vraiment sur le
long terme
un des points noirs étant régulièrement
d'amener un cavalier en c4 notamment que
l'abbé vite il peut passer par la has a
obligé de sacrifier le poulain
exactement mais le football en plus il
est parti en g2 ou en juin ça va pas
donc la dame on veut donner mieux placé
qu'en d2 c'est donc toute l'idée de
l'ordre de coûts choisi par laurent
frayssinet b5
on commence le contre jeu on profite du
fait que le fonds soit pas angers 2
sinon il y aurait eu 5
donc ça a effectivement c'est une
première chose ensuite mon seul avantage
de menacer des quatre très clairement
qu'ils chassent le quai c3 qui est une
orth pièces des blancs lionel attaque
bien de quatre attaques l'option 4 à 3
tout ça c'est normal
ouais faut baisser les noirs contre
attaque rapidement lu tion aux quatre
centrales 24 cette emprise fou j'ai deux
défenses semaine qu'avaient les b 17
on vient pour attaquer encore une fois
ce pion de quatre normales et ici h41
cei contre-attaquant maintenant on
tourne la cg scène puisque la tourache
on est protégé alors comme on l'a dit
stéphane dans la leçon sur g5 il est
très important de pouvoir bouger
lecavalier 6 1 17
donc il faut faire de la place mais dans
cette position et bien il ya un problème
immédiat c'est comme le fou n'est plus
en service mais il est déjà parti en
baisse est oui eh bien il pourrait y
avoir la vente suivante sur kbc 5 et le
couple ont envie de jouer
ouais puisque ça tape le tuant quatre ça
semble attaquer pion au carré alors y'a
g5 quand même quand même oui
puis on prend g5 ou pas ça change pas
grand chose change pas grand chose si on
prend une chambre et le tout retour
prochain en france et ouais cavalli pour
le 4 way ça a l'air bien ça pour les
noirs ça a l'air pas mal
mais le problème c'est qu'il n'ya tout
simplement cavalli prend oui mettons
qu'on reprenne du cavalier oui c'est
possible et enfin deux variantes il y a
g6 a quand même qui arrive comme un coup
de massue
là c'est vraiment extrêmement dur on
voit que les blancs on vous prend
n'aurait d'abord repris en quatre
exactement et jauger si ça se gagne
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est que le roi
noir ne veut plus aucune protection sur
l'échiquier
ouais c'est pas possible de protéger
droit les blancs vont jouer gros rock
avec donc une tour qui viendra sur la
colonne d extrêmement forte
le carillon des caps met la pression sur
le pion aux six donc toutes les cases
blanches autour du roi noir sont faibles
la dame de peut surgir en achetant
objecté un coup au prix d'un pion en a
on a eu d'atteindre un fleuve exploser
le roi même temps cette position après
h4 eh bien il faut trouver un truc qui
part j'ai 5 mais qui ne soit pas qui a
gagné ses cinq d'accord parce que la
menace est non seulement j'ai cinq
maires trajet this way il faut parer
tout ça et là il ya le coutour s'est
vite ça c'est le coût que laurent ne
connaissait a priori pas puisque cette
façon là on l'a vu plusieurs fois je me
suis fait exploser à chaque fois dans
les cahiers ces cinq épreuves
4 un bon là j'ai donc joué les tours
s'est vite 5 ou allemand qui a été joué
en deuxième division allemande
un seul parti l'idée c'est très curieux
a donc tu avais trouvés et avait trouvé
avoir un parti j'avais trouvé avant la
partie avant de championnat c'était la
préparation avant le championnat
laurent frayssinet je voulais le soigner
tout particulièrement ouais donc j'avais
préparé avant le temps d'un g5
ça n'a pas été jouer mais c'est possible
il faut comprendre son geste
qu'est ce qui se passe sur gestion prend
puis on prend si on prend on prendra
tout on prend la tour fou prend là et
d'un sacrifice de qualité tout reprend
ses droits à wind sacrifice de qualité
voilà donc la cie comprend on joue
cavalier prend aux 4 avec une très belle
position mais quand même j'ai six noms
il ya quand même j'ai six mais c'est pas
grave on peut sortir la dame sur la case
h4 enfin il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
contres jeu énorme contre je
après jesse c'est pas très grave avant
et autre chose donc là le coût principal
dans cette question ses pions prend
cavaliers et on joue tout simplement
tour c4 avec une position normale c'est
à dire que le pion n'arrive plusieurs
congés 6 c'est très compliqué mais c'est
tout à fait jouable
laurent frayssinet connaissent et ils
connaissaient ce truc là un accord après
tour s'est vite il a joué après très peu
de réflexion lecouffe ou des deux il
faut éviter le cavalier le sacrifice de
qualité en c3 un fou des deux par contre
là des avantages c'est que le cahier des
quatre est plus protégé
voilà tout à fait c'est l'inconvénient
majeur d'inconvénient à ce que ce qui
est des cartes en fait ses fans c'est
lui qui sert un juge et 5 g 6
ouais donc il faut l'attaquer d'un v6
d'imbéciles voilà ça permet de gagner un
temps de développement tout à fait
attaque le cavalier donc là le coût
normal c'est qui et b3 tout à fait
logique
sur quoi je jouerai km5 way avec quelque
chose de normal puisque et plus j'ai
cinq des six nations
le ciss n'étant plus en prise par cavani
ya parents l'autre l'autre alternative
c'est fou aux trois noms alors là je
reviens je serais revenu en courant
comme avis c'est à dire les enchantés de
faire nul oui tout à fait et le coût que
laurent frayssinet a pondu dans cette
position est tout à fait incroyable
surprenant surprenons j'étais le premier
surpris cavaliers prend pion aux six
sous incroyable ça alors c'est un
sacrifice de pièces et à l'air ça
simplifie 110 2
positionnelle cessa sacrifice
positionnelle puisque les blancs même
par toutes les ventes forcées du monde
ne revoit pas la pièce
ouais ils jouent pour une initiative
durable et persistante pions prend aussi
sont obligés d'accepter ce sens que ça
affaiblit les cases blanches du côté roy
exactement donc on voit que la dame donc
mon g5
c'est la continuation logique ouais j'ai
cinq ans même si le cavalier bouche des
problèmes en damascène qu'échec c'est
très compliqué il ya deux solutions ici
soit en prêt à angers 5 son joug qui
avaient vite tout de suite dans les deux
cas les avantages et inconvénients de
toute façon les banques contre les dames
h5 aidé à mettre 7
ouais donc ça les blancs ils arrivent
ils ont quand même du jeu mais le roi
peut quand même si chapelle on a une
passion puisqu'il brio lundi vite ses
sept des huit il peut il peut revenir
derrière ses pions du côté dames c'est
ce qu'on verra donc ici il faut choisir
entre cavaliers vitoux qui ont franchi 5
alors stéphane un conseil pour choisir
mais on a l'impression quand même un peu
la tourache 1 et caen alors plus active
que la tourache vite ça c'est lisse
c'est le cas c'est donc ce serait bien
de les changer et autre chose également
qu'ils le font un chien sera moins qu'on
voit là le fou en lâchant sera
catastrophique c'est à dire que si on
joue kg vite maintenant on peut avoir
peur des coups comme fou h 3à way qui
atteignait le monde si on tient tout à
fait désagréable donc ici sans calcul et
a priori pions pranger cinq pions projet
cinq mois et ça permet de limiter un
petit peu le fou est aussi la tour
blanche qui pourrait devenir en jeu
alors que la tourache 8 ne servait pas à
grand chose et là comme ça on est
tranquille points exactement on en fait
on a tué le fou qui peut parvenir il n'y
a pas de case malheureusement en donc ça
serait la case les uniquement défensif
pour l'instant à 4 2 il n'y a pas de
case ih 2 donc ça ne peut pas se
déplacer
voilà verra droit l'emplacement de ma
main la droite sur la diagonale
tout simplement parce qu' il ne peut pas
alors que quand il était chez nous ils
allaient en moi je crois hélas été très
désagréable qu'elle j'ai vite maintenant
l'initiative des blancs continuent d
acheter un match entre yande rock lo rwa
besson ne pouvait plus rocking wade vite
trois des huit dames f7 d'amérique
s'incruste pas mal parce que en fait la
pression causée des pièces morceaux sont
complètement enfermé
une fouille fuite le charisme d'huitre
sont pas développés maintenant le pion
aussi cette emprise donc les noirs
récupère au moins un pion pour la pièce
tout à fait plus une petite initiative
malheureusement ce n'est pas si simple
les noirs ont des les blancs ont déjà un
pion pour la pièce ouais ça c'est la
première marque mais sur quel luxe est
il y a un problème c'est que sur dame
croit aussi je crois que c'est ça que
l'on fera signer n'avait pas vu quand il
est chaud qui éprouvent aussi
d'apprendre sicile et le coût des cinq
des cinq super oui d'accord alors des
cinq sa contre attaque la dame voit la
dame prend dames chanoinesses d'échanger
les dames et j'ai changé programme des 5
est inacceptable surtout on prend des
saints qui est bien on échange tout en
échange même temps d'empreintes qui
entrera en fou pour un chien faut
prendre le cavalier on comprend et on se
retrouve avec une pièce de plus non je
crois qu'on ne reprend pas puisqu'ils
auraient peut-être grand roque way avec
menace de découverte la date du retour
on joue pour ça que je joue également
pour ses sets mais se reprend au noroît
pour marche très bien en fait miss monde
à secouer 3 way avec ici un net avantage
nord puisque on a une pièce de plus tout
simplement les pions blancs ne sont pas
dangereux on a changé depuis ont quand
même pour la pièce oui mais il ya plus
de dames
y a plus d' attaque et l'attaquent sans
attaque c'est très dur de justifier un
sacré petit deux pièces
donc après le coup kabadio 7 / d'un
proxy à des simples échanges général des
pièces et notamment des dames
donc c'est inacceptable laurent
frayssinet ne peut pas jouer d'un pro
sys donc là sa position devient critique
il joue pas le rock ouais là il faut
défendre le pion au 6 mai on peut pas
parce qu'on peut pas bouger ce qui a
aidé cette le fuite étant prises donc la
solution c'est le pousser au 500m voilà
effectivement on affaiblit la casse des
le cavalier pour venir là mais c'est pas
grave puisque elle est bien contrôlée
mais est-ce qu'on avait encore peur de
ça me prend 1,6 puisqu'on avait on n'a
pas toujours des scènes là c'est mon
père alors que oui maintenant faut
arracher un nul soit celle défendue
c'est plus du tout pareil ouais dans
cette position laurent frayssinet tout
un coup intéressant
g6 pour continuer l attaque mais le
meilleur coup était sans doute l'avancée
du psion bref je crois si les servir
second temps les frites suivi d'effets 5
et éventuellement f6 il fallait trouver
de l'activité avec les pions le coup
j'ai si ce n'est pas vraiment suffisant
dans cette mission il faut trouver le
bon coup pour les noirs stéphane alors
comment faire eh bien là c'est assez
simple en fait
la méthode de réflexion il faut voir
quelle pièce peut jouer et quelle pièce
ne peut pas jouer
donc là on s'aperçoit qu'on a une tour
ans évite qui peut pas vraiment être
améliorées le fouet fuites n'ont pas
bougé pas bougé wayne nuque et 17 non
puisqu'ils défendent fou un local et e7
peut-être me l'a pas beaucoup de cases
le calvados est il a pas de gaz des
clients c'est si c'est l'invasion
directs et 5
donc c'est pas possible non plus est il
donc qu'est ce qui reste
le fourbe et 7 non non est-ce que c'est
pas où aller ouais pousser les pions
ça a l'air un peu optimiste donc en fait
le plan on le trouve c'est aurait
replacer la dame des six et pour ça il
faut aller sur la teste ses quatre
vingts d'accord chasser la dame et
recettes
ah oui voilà le tranquille en fait sans
se presser donc le coup ces dames c6 une
c6 très fort coup fouet trois joué par
laurent frayssinet donc là je fais la
faute énorme faute puisque quand même
sous pression il faut bien lire laurent
frayssinet en train de masser ces pièces
on sait pas trop ce qui fait mais enfin
ça fait peur dans cette pression joueurs
du jouet d'un de ces quatre ans mais qui
a l'air de bien mais je n'ai pas vu
quelque chose de a priori assez simple
quand même ouais c'était tout reprend
dès 6 ans des six donc effectivement
d'assaut m16 salaire normal dans un pion
et là n'ont pas pu on prend 27 mai tous
mes six échecs à très problématique
ah oui qui gagne et qui récupère une
pièce le quai 17 et cloud et donc sur
trois ans 8 ça récupère une pièce si on
prend on va prendre tout reprendre 17
tours prend 17 avec davantage le blanc
avec guingamp l'a tout simplement c'est
très facile à gagner ils ne sont plus
maintenant une tour très active donc ça
ça ne va pas alors que dans cette
pression je n'ai pas vu quelque chose
donc la position de départ étant celle
là ouais surnomment ses quatre tours
prend des six laurent frayssinet
l'indiqué après la partie que croissent
et 7 et c'est fini à quoi ses sept
petits coups intermédiaires on est vite
tombé six échecs on attaque la tour on
échangera les dames au coup d'après et
ici c'est tout simplement gagnant
facilement
donc voilà la faute dans cette position
je n'ai pas vu de ces quatre géants font
tourner comme on dit et donc j'ai joué
le coup à 5
et là il faut croire que j'ai vraiment
une chute de
de forme ouais puisque j'ai pas vu la
réponse de laurent frayssinet qui est
quand même un coût assez simple beaucoup
d'âmes aussi pas mal attaque l'option
des six lots gros problème maintenant
c'est que sur ces 7 mai en prend quand
même une option des siciliens qui avait
prouvé 5 et châteauroux à oui maintenant
il ya échec récupère tous alors qu'avant
il ya six protéger des scènes qui tout à
fait donc ici sur m6 je m'aperçois du
drame je me dis ça y est il a eu un
dommage tant pis da c'est fini je vois
vraiment plus de défense ici ouais je
veux défendre l'option des six mais je
peux pas vous dire c'est que ça défend
pas enfin cette emprise calais s'est
vite j'ai pas le droit
le fou je peux pas le faire jouer je
vois je voyais pas donc bon je me suis
quand même rappeler que j'avais une
pièce de plus donc je les rejoins les
rangs du il y avait des promotions
jessica l'air pas mal puisque ça c'est
enlève ce pion justice qu'elle est un
peu embêtant se défendent et 6 défendez
6 mai sapeurs une pièce quand même
puisque adam projet six mois c'est le
problème donc ici on se retrouve donc
les blancs reviennent dans la partie
complètement mais ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que toute la partie donc un but
leur foi chain mal placé ouais c'est
important ici l'attak de l'attak
maintenant à changer de camp ce n'est
plus les blancs qui attaque
oui parce que son élève 4 le cavalier
peut pas bouger sinon il ya matin ses
deux exactement donc d4 donc ça a l'air
de ça a l'air d'être une bonne contre
attaque
effectivement mais ici il ya une suite
force et bien entendu qui fait que les
blancs ne perd pas la pièce a donc ils
ont le coup j'ai cinq échecs
voilà fuji simple échec donc dans cette
position il ya fou aux 7 qui fait nul de
manière forcée puisque fou prend fou
aura prend il ya échec perpétuelle après
avis d'un projet cette voie là et si le
roi violence et 7 il ya toujours qu'il
ya des cinq échecs que j'ai pas
spécialement envie après phocéenne en
tout cas et en plus je voulais pas/je
fawcett parce que
bon déjà un que j'ai pas vu que ça
faisait nul sinon j'aurais peut-être
joué et 2 je préférais le coup que j'ai
joué au fc sète
ouais mais qui donc qui permet car il ya
des scènes que j'ai effectivement mais
le roi s'en va et je vais aller en b
vite me lâcherai extrêmement bien
protégé quand même toujours une contre
attaque sur ces 2 alors que s'est il
passé ici en france à sept îles a joué à
prouver qu'à prendre une claque d'abord
en a fait une faute mais bon si on prend
les quatre cas mais les dessins kesha
l'air de récupérer le plus handicapé 4
exact savoir otages restés deux robes et
8 et maintenant ils auraient pu prendre
b4
il ne l'a pas fait oui ça a l'air bien
de prendre en bi-classe ça protège ses
deux prochains coups mal joués c2 c3
probablement exactement mais là il y à
damas quatre attaques lecavalier 4-1 sur
ces 3 stéphane ses clous et et le renard
avec la rivalité serait tant prisée pas
prendre un cavalier et ici je ne vois
pas de défense pour les blancs ça te
fait désagréable on peut pas défendre le
cavalier puisque fou des deux ya matt
williams attend un lecavalier est en
prise mais tout à fait il n'y a pas de
solution ici donc ça ça ne va pas donc
ça va pas après roye b vite
laurent frayssinet jeu autour des 2
tours d2 est ici comme il l'a confié
après la partie ne l'a pas vu le coup de
massue les noirs jouent et gagnent dans
cette position il y un gain pour trouver
le gain s'était fait un passé dans
libération qui est passé dans libération
et celle ci qui ont été mis dans
libération un journal dans la rubrique
de jean pierre mercier il faut passer la
dame sur la colonne pas mais ça ne
suffira pas puisque l'hébergeur hongrois
bien donc il faut qu'il y ait quelque
chose contre eux roi bien donc pour ça
et bien le coup s'impose de lui-même ces
dames à 6 qui permet de faire un échec
en f1 aussi exaspéré le fou achats voilà
donc des masses is known as dame un
échec des zones à cette année ça et
menace ses limites c'est demain alors
sur c2 c3 qui permet d'avoir la caste et
de évidemment il ya la fameuse il ya le
fameux l'art peut-être détroit aurait
tout à fait qu'il est
là on ferme le cercueil comme on dit
voilà exactement on empêche de sortir
voilà simplement doublé 3 et les menaces
toujours d'amin en manhattan est un
athée et en plus le pion b3 et très
dangereux oui donc ici problème pour
pour les blancs laurent frayssinet jour
roi bien très logiquement way damev un
échec
roy 2 3 à 2 hélas ne pas prendre le fou
agen ce fou est trop mauvais il ne
mérite pas d'être pris d'autant plus que
si on prend deux fois chacun et bien il
ya contre je ouais c'est un clin d'oeil
même pour jouer maintenant
il est contre jour rapide à pfastatt
c'est à dire 7,5 cette attaque du pion
du site en fait c'est une attaque qui va
se passer sur case noire puisque la part
ce coup qui avait lieu de 7 ans tue le
foot cases noires et donc la menace ces
dames prend un pion des six avec la dame
qui revient en jeu on revient aux
bécanes lada machin maintenant a pris la
place du fou donc extrêmement mauvaise
position se foutait complètement hors
jeu donkey s'il faut pas jouer ça il
faut pas prendre le foie à mon avis j'ai
enfin en tout cas ce que j'ai joué à
leur meilleur damas six échecs menaçant
de faire nul ne la sent de faire nul
laurent frayssinet toxiques d'accepter
la nulle puisque s'il tente de
s'échapper à la croix b 3 il va
décaisser cinq échecs
ouais par matic 10 mètres maths on croit
bien damée fin alors je serai peut-être
les coûts pour une raison très simple
stéphane le fameux geste technique comme
on dit c'est qu'on a 30 secondes par
coup supplémentaire donc ça permet de
rajouter un peu de temps voilà donc il
faut pas les répéter trois fois sinon
c'est nul ouais mais deux fois ça va
mais on a gagné une minute avec la
manipulation comme je commence à être
mal autant et que je voulais pas non
plus m'aventurer dans des calculs qui ne
marche pas et bien petit geste technique
on gagne une minute ancrant à deux roues
à deux est là pour être sûr b3 échec
b trois échecs voilà ça c'est le cousin
ça c'est le coût qui gagne le coup qui
gagne définitivement si on prend b3 et
forcé on peut regarder voire même des
rois prendre des trois il ya le ku'damm
c4 probablement cassé quatre échecs à
trois ris forcé pour à 3 forcé et là je
crois que damas 6-3 b3 et on doit monter
la tour à nous dire qu'elle et ses cinq
essais 5 voilà c'est à peu près la même
thématique qu'avant et amath la lie à
matemale battant 5
forcément ces trois forces et ses 3 ou
web et 4 enfin c'est au choix de toute
façon ça va aller très vite et une tour
oui il ya une dame est un cavalier
laïque et détroit pas de problème c est
qu après trois échecs roi b3 forcé bon
on peut regarder jusqu'au match mais mon
cas et c'est un a est le cas rien c'est
un rober casadéens pour ces quatre là
tant ces quatre malades tout simplement
il faut quand même trop et c'est quoi
oui libre et ses coûts mais en fait y'a
pas besoin de les calculer puisqu'on
sait que on sait que ça y est si on voit
roi prend b3 on regarde le début juste
dams et 4 hongrois 3 damas six robes et
trois cahiers ces cinq là on s'arrête
ouais on s'arrête si ya pas de maths
dans cette position il n'y a plus qu'à
arrêter et plus qu'à tout arrêter parce
que c'est pâques aussi pourquoi il ya
forcément le matin les trois échecs puis
on prend b3 oui tour c'est un menace
matt menace matt petites menaces
désagréable fait ce que j'ai jamais
voulu que la rentrée ciné le temps que
bécaye diop 7 qui était le coup qui
redonnait espoir aux blancs dames 1 8
échecs ça ce désespoir
ça sert à pas grand chose tout s'est
vite et font tout aura trois seul coup
pour pas se fermer en b3 alors il ya b3
b4 un beckham et quatre ans pour se
ménager une porte de sortie
b4 alors commencer un rassemblement d'un
psychiatre échecs dames c4 et celle
d'homs et 4 et voilà ça c'est en fait
ces dames à 6 à damas six robes et 3 et
dames c'est calme maintenant
et voilà hélas ce roi 3,4 à tours 1-1
voilà exactement la sedona tu joues pour
le matin ce flash a été reprise tout le
temps dans le projet mais ça ne sert à
rien donc après tout ces vies 3 3 a été
joué et là il ya le match fort c'est
assez simple battant troyes où damas six
échecs dames à 600 miles encarté à la
force et d'amd cette glace et le
vraiment le match du couloir à ses lamas
du coup on repousse qu'il aille sur
n'importe quelle case dit même punition
pour un math toi hein tout simplement
voilà donc une belle contre attaque
qu'en partie
une belle partie quand même avec un
sacrifice intéressant quand même de
laurent frayssinet ouais c'est pas
vraiment c'est un sacrifice complètement
faux un sacrifice avec beaucoup de jeu
mauvaise réaction de ma part qui
entraîne une position complexe et
ensuite au moment de se défendre laurent
frayssinet a craqué en premier donc de
toutes façons il est passé à côté de son
chant théâtre ans je ne sais pas si
c'est suite à cette partie qui lui est
un peu cassé le moral qui est possible
oui mais il avait perdu en revanche il
avait déjà perdu aventure s'ils doivent
maintenant un contrôle hoffman donc il
en fait il a mal commencé cependant il
n'a jamais réussi roi là c'est vraiment
bien
quand on commence mal on essaie de se
refaire et souvent ça permet de
s'enfoncer un peu plus c'est ce qui lui
est arrivé donc laurent frayssinet voilà
désolé qui était pourtant un des favoris
qui était pourtant des trois favoris
puisqu'ils avaient le troisième lots
alors c'était une petite séquence
actualité en bref donc match europe asie
je sais pas si tu as suivi un petit peu
way match en partie rapide match de
parties rapides avec la présence de
détiennent bacrot justement aux côtés de
kasparov kasparov qui menait la
délégation européenne ont sur 12,1 garry
kasparov
j'ai fait ça tue encore ce score qui tue
un score qui tu es
donc on sur 12 en fait c'était tout
simplement une boucherie puisqu'on a
gagné on a gagné l'europe a gagné 47 et
lee 24 et demi chez les hommes mais on
rencontre a perdu chez les femmes en
revanche chez les femmes on s'est fait
tout à fait pulvériser ce qui fait que
le score final est de 58 à 46 pour
l'europe
voilà donc ce match europe asie brendan
dans la tourmente alors stéphane latour
avis nous intéresse énormément mais deux
choses m'ont première chose annulation
du match homme machine
sinon je vous attends terme du match
enfin je sais ça part un peu doux 2
parce que c'était quand même ans est
prévu comme en octobre
en octobre je sais pas disent que c'est
à cause des attentats aux états unis bon
c'est la bonne excuse ont maintenant
toutes les compétitions sportives en
redémarrer oui
que ce soit le foot autre chose dans mon
avis voici une bonne excuse je sais pas
si bizarre aussi bizarre bon ben
maintenant à priori à vue quand même une
déclaration du sultan de bahreïn oui un
respectable là où ça va se passer
donc a priori quand même bon je pense
que ça va quand même avoir lieu mais
c'est bizarre c'est quand même bien
cycle des championnats du monde alors le
tour des candidats qui étaient prévus à
dortmund en 2002 on ne sait pas s'il est
maintenu ou pas mais en tout cas
kasparov qui participera pas alors ça
c'est du grand casse par an grâce à ses
différents kasparov parce que ça fait
des années qu'ils cherchaient un sponsor
pour redémarrer
on avait l'impression que ce qui tenait
à coeur c'est qu'il ya de nouveau des
matches longs pour déterminer avec des
qualifications avait des qualifications
candidats pour déterminer le champion du
monde
il trouve un sponsor bon ils n'ont pas
le temps de faire des calices des
machins parce que c'est là ils
choisissent chronique comme challenger
manque de bol hyper bon c'est vrai que
c'était pas de chance ça c'était pas
prévu c'est pas prévu parce que ce que
caps kasparov prévoit c'est que je suis
champion du monde et il ya les
challengers qui viennent pour se faire
battre et je reste championne du monde
mais malheureusement crâne qui gagne
donc en quelque sorte se reprendre
puisque il se met à gagner tous les
tournois de suite et on va écouter
oui soyons sérieux je suis quand même le
meilleur joueur du monde
je n'ai pas joué des candidats ouais
mais c'est voilà ce qu'il dit l'enfant
en tout cas une fois plus kasparov et
complètement pas crédible il faut bien
le faut bien le dire
il crée une organisation il s'en va
l'année d'après c'est comme d'habitude
du n'importe quoi moi une star garry
kasparov là on se demande à quoi il va
se rapprocher maintenant parce qu'il
n'est plus champion du monde puisqu'il a
été battu par kramnik oui les plus à la
fidèle de la fidh est donc là il peut
plus dire je suis championne monde
j'attends d'avoir un match qu est-ce qui
va faire voilà donc brain games en fait
dans la tourmente
il faut bien le dire a rohff c'est sûr
que dans le côté bon classement fait
quasiment fait je sais pas il est
quasiment assuré de gagner ce match en
moins alors dernières news équipe de
france jeune et prometteuse avec
etienne bacrot laurent frayssinet
christian bauer jean-marc degraeve et le
petit dernier c'est le petit dernier
bauer il est très fort d'ailleurs c'est
christian bauer n'a accompagné par jean
claude main qui représentera la france
aux championnats d'europe par équipes
une très travaillé qui alors stéphane
merci d'avoir suivi cette édition
d'avoir participé de nous avoir éclairé
une fois de plus de tes conseils on se
donne rendez vous la semaine prochaine
peut-être avec une nouvelle formule on
vous en dira plus merci